started his game well not the ready but
similar structures did appear afterwards
but it started with one c4 with the
english opening
yeah it's it's the english and very
interesting to see how also lag one them
reacts so with e5 so yeah it was not c4
e5 it was c4 knight f6 knight system e5
knight fc knight c6 g3 d5 cd knight d5
bishop g2 bishop c5
castles castles queen c2 i mean this
bishop c5 line i think it's called the
glitch variation i think for the very
first time on the highest level krishuk
introduced it against the pavilion of i
think it was in in geneva grand prix in
2017 in july
if i'm not mistaken because i heard the
the press conference afterwards and
grishchuck went on to win such a
moderate game from the black side that i
think everybody who was in the
who was interested in the chester he was
thinking like wow a completely new
concept and by now it's one of the main
reactions all right super interesting
stuff lots of theoretical discussion so
black has fallen back with the bishop to
b6 just a prophylactic move against b4
and this also implies that now b4 you
can also aim to meet it with knight d4
or a5 b5 knight d4 feels quite
harmonious queen b7 connecting the
rogues eyeing the move bishop f5 or
bishop h3 trading off that bishop uh to
me at first sight it looks like la quang
liam
solved all opening problems to play
against the bishop on b6 he has kept
this e3 f2 pawns uh
but once they gets the feeling that yes
it's interesting what you say about this
opening that white is never very
ambitious from the very start you just
want a game that's what he's got i still
think liam is pretty pleased with the
outcome the fact that against the world
champion it's the first game of the day
you start off with a comfortable
position with black uh i think that's
that's good news and peter you were
mentioning playing against the bishop
magnus chooses to make the move knight
a4 hitting it immediately also
threatening the move knight c5 i i don't
know maybe the the trick is some some
queen syste and
la quang liam goes look f8 okay i'm
little bit surprised
because i i really felt like this bishop
f5 is the move that that would bother me
from the right side uh this position on
the other hand has gone completely
different from what we were thinking
peter uh do you want to take it from
where we left it last because no bishop
f5 happened
yes yes no bishop f5 and i somehow feel
that with rookie 8 maybe
liam has missed this default idea that
actually white can try to strike
immediately in the center because i'm
not such a big fan if if you have to
give up this light square bishop but
okay uh the problem was that the move d4
was a very very subtle move order that
white is not grabbing on b6 first he
keeps all the options open
after d4 if black takes on d4 then
magnus would jump on taking on b6 and
after cb6 he would take knight d4 with
clear advantage
solving all the structural problems
and so if black plays the move e5 e4
then by jumps 95 that's that's also a
move that hurts black
big time so bishop fc was kind of forced
takes takes
he look fd1
and of course it's a very nice judgment
by magnus feeling that
i mean uh it looks like black is having
things under constant on d4 but white is
starting to take on b6 and take on d4 so
liam uses his chance with knight e5 to
create complications
hitting the bishop white took on b7
and black played the move dc
magnus opted for this bishop takes e5
d takes c
2 and luke takes d7 on the board now
knight december take knight d7 we do
ideas after loop c1 i gonna jump knight
c5
and uh
no time to take knight c5 because
there's rook d1 so white has to take the
c2 pawn yes you have to take and then i
might take on bc but it might be a very
bad ending because takes takes look b2
you you end up winning material
we have something very similar on the
board so let's just go to our live
position instead of bishop c3 magnus
came all the way back to b2 so more
control on the c1 square which makes at
least threats like rook d8 rook d1 less
dangerous because the rook will be
defended on c1 the move knight c5 played
immediately hitting that pawn on b3 but
doesn't this allow knight takes c5
bishop c5 rook c1 and then he wants to
go rook b8 i think that's the idea yes
yes that's that's the idea i mean it's
very much in the spirit okay idea and
magnus goes look c1 immediately yeah he
has to do this
he has to do this and basically he has
to capture on b3 no yeah but then the
problem is that the knight is kind of
trapped yeah how nice that white steel
did not captured on b6 yeah white is
going to win the c2 pawn eventually
yes and you still have the weaknesses on
on a5 and c7 yeah liam goes for knight
xbc look takes c to f6 f6 of course a
very very nice move first of all
creating love for the king getting ready
to bring the king closer
and also shutting down the bishop on b2
on the long diagonal oh yeah this is a
very very good move
and magnus comes also with the king king
f1 the only problem for liam is that
white's play of bringing his king is
much more effective because black has
this vulnerable knight on bc imagine
just some king he took this the king c4
walk and the knight on beast is trapped
yeah i go look c4 i i only gonna collect
this a4 pawn but still this is already
some kind of achievement for black
because this look and game has the
tendency of finally reaching four versus
three on the king side definitely a very
good chance to escape
but i also saw now that lakwang liam had
a bishop on b8 how did that happen
so magnus of course doing magnus things
he's not allowing this lucan game no
never he says you know what you have
really uncoordinated pieces
and yeah rook b2 bishop a7 king e2 and
now there is this pin along the b5 the
king is coming closer
king d5 e4 check very very important
because white wants to get to the c4
square with his king that's why he's
heading king c6 king c4
knight is forced to see one wow i mean i
have never seen something like this that
black has a closed bishop on b8 with the
pawn on c7 and the kind of trapped
knight on c1 also these are opposite
squares that bishop on ba that's the
square the knight belongs to at the
start of the game and where black's
knight is right now and c1 is where we
have the bishop at the start of the game
so it's switch and not a happy switch
yeah no not at all and okay this this is
not just technically completely winning
for magnus nia
you've got to go knight i mean he's
thinking knight g1 because knight d4
maybe runs into bishop e3 and you just
end up
pinning and winning that night yeah but
after knight g1 i think bishop east is
very very nice forcing the threat of the
bishops and after bishop is the king is
the knight is forever clapped after
knight hd white plays f4 and goodbye
knight yeah took control of all the the
tactics that were happening on the board
you remember after d3 d take c2 just all
aspects of the game were handled really
well by him yeah absolutely i mean but
this is this is the typical story if you
give magnus the slightest chance he will
be merciless yeah and uh he's not
incredibly focused i still tend to
believe that luka v8 was the cause of
all black's problems i mean the move
bishop f5 should have been somehow
included i i have this feeling but okay
rook f8 d4 bishop fc takes takes all
these tactical skill mesh
magnus was in total control dc
the bishop takes e5
dtx to look d7 i mean i'm going here
fast because we have discussed this
during the broadcast already so bishop
takes it luke takes eight the move
bishop b2 was very very nice and we
talked about it that yeah what is
important difference
this this retreat